Orion continues to fly smoothly on all
of its systems in excellent shape it is
a site that never ceases to amaze Earth
in all its majesty and equally
bewildering the fact that only an hour
later Orion was back home we should be
performing uh the skip entry maneuver
momentarily it's dizzying descent neared
speeds of 25
000 miles an hour both mind and Horizon
bending Orion's speed now down to Mach
6. for those down below off the coast of
California it was an anxious wait this
flight was to test NASA's Next
Generation spaceship no one was on board
this time but the hope is they will be
soon and we're on Mains parachutes
deployed this was the first sign things
had gone to plan a full inspection is
still to come of course but for now it
is mission accomplished Splashdown
Orion back on Earth
the date chosen for Splashdown was a nod
to space travel folklore
it's 50 years to the day since this
happened when the crew of Apollo 17
became the last astronauts to walk on
the moon now NASA wants to do that again
this time we go back to the Moon to
learn to live to work
to invent to create
in order to go on it is the beginning of
the new beginning
and that is to explore the heavens
Orion's launch last month marked the
start of the Artemis program it hopes to
land people on the moon in three years
and then to establish a base there as a
stepping stone to Mars and Beyond
this time was just a flyby a glimpse of
what's to come and a reminder that in
half a century mankind has gone no
further Ivor Bennett Sky News